bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france cette décision du
parlement égyptien pour quelles raisons
mais d'abord la décidant du parlement
égyptien répond à la demande formulée
par l'assemblée nationale de tobrouk
c'est que la seule institution élue de
de la libye depuis 2014 et dont le
président monsieur aguilas allez y ça et
par la constitution libyenne chef d'état
par intérim
cette cette assemblée qui était avant à
tripoli et qui avaient fui tripoli en
2014 lorsque les islamistes ont pris le
contrôle de la capitale après avoir
perdu les élections et la majorité à
l'assemblée s'était réfugié à tobrouk et
maintenant elle est à bengazi
elle s'est réunie elle a demandé ainsi
que le conseil nationale des tribus
libyennes
ils ont demandé à al ahly egypte et aux
émirats arabes unis d'intervenir et de
venir les aider
de la même façon que le gn à de monsieur
sa rage avait demandé à la turquie
d'intervenir en libye il ya maintenant
près de trois mois donc c'est une
assemblée élue légitime populaire qu'est
la seule légitimité populaire de la
libye puisque monsieur sage n'a qu'une
légitimité onusienne qui a décidé de
faire venir l'egypte et donc monsieur al
sisi le président égyptien qui avait
massé ses blindés ses troupes à la
frontière avec la libye est en capacité
maintenant d'intervenir et de venir
soutenir la ligne de front qui va de
syrte
ajout fera alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire justement sur l'appel de la turquie
aussi qui s'invite dans cette crise
libyenne qui appelle à mettre fin au
soutien aux forces du maréchal haftar il
est quand même cocasse de voir monsieur
erdogan éructer contre les interventions
de l'egypte est désert des émirats
arabes unis qui ont toujours été les
alliés de la libye et de monsieur haftar
alors que lui même s'est imposé à
débarquer en libye
avec treize miliciens syrien islamistes
ils y apprennent maintenant de deux mois
et demi deux mois qu'ils occupent
tripoli qui dirige tripoli avec son
ministre de la défense qui il ya encore
quelques jours de tripoli disais que
plus jamais la turquie ne quitterait la
libye 1 c'est monsieur monsieur là car
son mini la défense qui faisait cette
déclaration tonitruante et donc comment
peut-il lui interdire aux alliés de
monsieur haftar de venir l'aider alors
que lui même s'est imposé directement
sur le sol libyen et pourquoi ne demande
pas aussi à la russie de partir on est
étonné quand même puisqu'on sait que les
russes soutiennent haftar les rues sont
présents c'est un mig 29 qui a détruit à
quelques jours quasiment toute la base
aérienne d'al watyah qui était tenu par
à part les syriens et les milices du gn
1 et à l'ouest de la libye de la libye
et monsieur erdogan ne dit rien à
monsieur poutine
ce qu'on sait très bien que s'ils
cherchent noise monsieur poutine la
réaction va être brutal alors peut-être
qu'on peut faire un point sur les forces
en présence qui soutient justement le
maréchal haftar et qui soutient le
gouvernement à tripoli même si
actuellement
l'arabie saoudite l'egypte le tchad des
émirats arabes unis et la russie
soutiennent lemarchal haftar la france
ne le fait pas officiellement annoncé
qu'elle et elle est plus du côté de
l'homme fort de benghazi que du côté du
fantoche de tripoli et du côté de
tripoli et la turquie et le qatar
uniquement alors on peut se poser la
question que fait l'union européenne
pourquoi l'union européenne qui est
directement concerné par la libye par
rapport à l'histoire et par rapport au
présent et au futur
sachant que la libye est un à deux cents
kilomètres des côtes italiennes
que fait que fait l'union européenne
alors on me dirait en ce moment elle est
à bruxelles en réunion de conseil
européen
et j'espère que dans les jours prochains
si le plan de relance se repère réussi
madame merkel qui préside le conseil
européen et le président macron prendre
une initiative sur la libye l'europe ne
peut pas rester absentes de la libye
c'est la sécurité maritime de tout le
front sud de l'europe qui est en jeu en
libye et donc dire il est temps de
réagir ce n'est plus un problème de
l'otan vous dites bien que l'ayant
rappelle effectivement été très occupé
en ce moment mais quelles sont les
chances finalement de sortir la libye du
du chaos depuis la chute du guide libyen
mouammar kadhafi ce tyran 2011
depuis neuf ans ce pays est en guerre
depuis neuf ans l'onu a été incapable
d'arriver à une médiation politique la
france en plus d'ailleurs et d'autres
pays et donc puisque la solution
militaire choisie par monsieur haftar
n'a pas abouti avec la prise de tripoli
à cause monsieur erdogan
bien que le maréchal contrôler les deux
tiers du pays
il faut maintenant arriver une solution
politique il faut mettre autour de la
table les parties prenantes sans
discrimination est arrivé un accord
politique
cet accord politique passera
probablement par le départ de monsieur
sa rage et par la mise en place d'un
nouveau conseil présidentiel et d'un
nouveau gouvernement d'union nationale
est-ce que cet accord sera trouvé à
genève à berlin ou à ou ailleurs je ne
sais pas mais il est il est temps il est
en ce pays a trop souffert de
l'incapacité des institutions
internationales à régler le problème de
l'incapacité de l'union africaine à
régler le problème de l'incapacité de
l'union européenne à régler le problème
et donc il est temps maintenant puisque
nous sommes sous protectorat russo
turques que ce pays revienne à sa terre
africaine et reviennent dans le giron de
la méditerranée et de notre espace
commun merci beaucoup à vous à michel
scarbonchi d'appel rappelle que vous
êtes ancien député européen consultant
sur le moyen orient